It is impossible to know just how many microbial
species there are in the world.
One recent estimate put the number somewhere
around 1 trillion species.
And the vast majority of those organisms still
have yet to be discovered.
But even with our relatively limited knowledge
of the microcosmos, being able to identify
microbes when we can is important, from helping
doctors diagnose their patients to guiding
scientists through their observations.
And sometimes the goals are a little less
urgent but still meaningful.
Like for James, our Master of Microscopes
who collects these organisms and tends to
them, and for the rest of us on the Journey
to the Microcosmos team who want to share
what we've learned.
We love showing off these organisms, and the
more specific we can get when we identify
them, the more we can tell you about their
lives.
But even if we humans have only discovered
a small fraction of all the microbes, there's
still a lot that we have found and named,
so figuring out what exactly is in our samples
can be difficult.
It’s like playing the board game Guess Who?,
but first you have to solve a maze to find
the right board.
And even when you do find it, you realize
you are playing with the largest Guess Who?
board ever, and still, you can’t be sure
it even holds the answer
As we'll talk about later, scientists have
devised a number of molecular methods that
make this task less daunting.
But we do things the old-fashioned way: we
just look at the organisms.
We collect our samples from nature, peering
in to an assembly of microscopic animals and
single-celled creatures, looking for clues
in their morphology that will hopefully reveal
what they are.
So come along with us.
Let’s take you through some of the questions
that help guide us through this process.
The best place to start is to ask yourself,
in the broadest sense, what you are looking at.
Is it multicellular?
Is it a unicellular eukaryote?
A prokaryote?
We'll start with the multicellular organisms,
in part because they're generally a little
easier to identify.
There are fewer of them in total, and their
bodies just have more going on, and that means
that there’s more clues for us to find.
Let's take the tardigrade, as an example,
but pretend that you don't know what tardigrades
look like.
You went down to your favorite pond, gathered
some water, and now you're looking at what
you collected through the microscope.
On the other side is this delightful, bumbling
bit of life.
You see some stubby legs waving around, a
pair of eyes, and maybe some strange things
moving around inside its body.
All those details are helpful.
Legs are a great clue, as are eyes.
And inside, the moving things you're watching
seem a bit like organs.
If you weren't sure that you were looking
at a multicellular organism before,
you probably are now.
And beyond what you see, there’s also what
you know, you know that you got this little
guy from a pond, meaning a freshwater environment.
That means you can rule out organisms that
only live in marine environments.
So what now?
You might be able to get help from a freshwater
biology book, but if you're a hobbyist, those
books might not be worth the cost.
Luckily, as old-fashioned as our methodology
is, we have a resource that the microbe hunters
of yore did not: the good ol’ internet,
a source not just of cat pictures and arguments,
but also of the many microorganisms that scientists
and science enthusiasts like yourself have
studied and documented.
Sometimes, all you need to do is just a simple
search for something like "freshwater microscopic
animal" and look through images until you
find something that matches what you're looking at.
Now, of course, "freshwater microscopic animal"
can bring up a whole range of species, like
rotifers, hydras, and gastrotrichs.
But each of those animals is very different
from the others, which can help narrow down
what your unidentified microbial organism
is and is not.
If you find this process overwhelming at first,
because you are trying to narrow down the
vastness of the microcosmos into just one
species, that’s okay!
Every time you do this, you will get better
at it.
It takes years of practice and experience
to figure out how to use all of the information
available to you and pick out the most useful details.
And like a baby tardigrade waving its legs
for the first time, we all have to start somewhere.
With single-celled eukaryotes, the process
starts to get more difficult.
You won't see the complex structures and systems
that distinguish multicellular organisms,
but you will see organelles that can help
clarify what you're looking at.
For example, one major clue can be picking
out which organisms have those beating hairs
called cilia versus which ones have more whip-like
hair called flagella.
And if you see the green color of chloroplasts,
you know that you need to find an organism
capable of photosynthesis.
For example, what if you see the tell-tale
trumpet morphology in your collection?
“Aha,” you might say, “that is a Stentor!”
And you would be correct, but which Stentor?
While Stentors have varying numbers of micronuclei,
these are hard to see without staining.
The macronucleus, however, is visible and
can be helpful.
For Stentor coeruleus, the macronucleus resembles
beads strung together across the cell which
is called a moniliform nucleus.
Stentor polymorphous also has a moniliform
nucleus, but it’s easier to distinguish
from the Stentor coeruleus because of the
endosymbiotic algae that turn it green.
Stentor igneus, by contrast, is smaller, and
has pink pigments, and contains an oval macronucleus.
Stentors are a relatively easier genus to
pick apart because there are only about 20
species of Stentors to decide between.
Other genera can have hundreds of species,
and the differences might be more subtle.That’s
why sometimes you’ll see our organisms labeled
by the most narrow description we feel comfortable
giving, whether that’s identifying an organism
solely by its genus, or even going more broad
and just calling it a “ciliate.”
These are cases where we just don’t know
enough...yet.
For those of you who remember our mystery,
real time video, it took James a year to be
sure of what organisms he was watching.
And until he identified the mystery organism, we didn’t know what was happening in that video.
And of course it’s even more challenging
to identify bacteria.
We can use morphology to parse out cyanobacteria
and sulfur bacteria.
But with most of the bacteria in our samples,
it's just impossible to tell without genetic
sequencing, a technique that is not in our
toolkit at the moment.
And for us, that's okay.
But there are cases where it's important to
dig further, and scientists have developed
many molecular techniques to identify the
microbes in their samples.
There are stains to emphasize certain identifying
structures, and biochemical tests to reveal
the presence of specific enzymes.
Also, of course, there’s gene sequencing
and other more advanced chemical methods to
probe what species a sample contains.
For James, who does the work of identifying
our microbes without these molecular tests,
what he's able to name comes from years of studying and memorizing the drawings and pictures
he’s found in various books and keys, as
well an ongoing habit of reading papers every day.
It's more a way of life, a habit borne out
of science, an art, a labor of love.
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And all of these people on the screen right
now, these are our patrons on Patreon.
We only have one Patreon tier, it’s $8 a
month.
And with it, you get your name featured in
the end of our video here, a weekly hi-resolution
image of one of our micro friends, and an
extended video featuring uncut footage with
no narration from me, just Andrew Huang’s
wonderful music.
And if you want to join up and help us out,
you can do that at patreon.com/journeytomicro.
If you want to see more from our Master of Microscopes James, check out Jam & Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, just
go to youtube.com/microcosmos.